what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing a future for humanity the
commission has decided to find google
4.34 billion
[Music]
is euros man on the moon moment we are
innovating here and we hope that you
like it
welcome to europe calling a series of
podcasts brought to you by the european
commission
looking at the politics and policies of
the union today
with me paul anderson and me stephen
jones
today in the fight against covert things
are starting to look promising in europe
vaccination rates are rising rapidly an
agreement has been reached
across the 27 member states on eu-wide
digital covert certificates
so stephen what does this mean for us
holidays
meals on the terrace in the soft setting
sun
a rush of confidence at the real
prospect of economic pickup
led by fast reactive sectors like
construction
hospitality and tourism maybe the music
festivals too
that europe is so famous for this will
be the meat of today's edition of europe
calling
with our special guest cherry breton
european commissioner for the internal
market
a warm welcome commissioner from me and
paul and to you our listeners
we'll be looking with commissioner
breton at europe's industrial strategy
updated to take account of the setbacks
as well as the opportunities of covid
we'll also examine the covid recovery
plan
first agreed way back last year and now
given the green light by the union
freeing it and member states to raise
and
spend money on projects it's called next
generation eu
this is what the european commission
president ursula fondo lyon
had to say about it as she announced the
go-ahead to member states just recently
reminding us of the eye-watering sums
involved
it will bring 750 billion euros to
repair our economies
but also to build them better greener
more digital more resilient so how will
the plan roll out in the following weeks
the commission will go to the capital
markets to start raising the funds for
next generation
eu so next generation eu can provide the
investments
we need to recover from the crisis
before we come to our interview with
monsieur britton
let's feel the mood in different parts
of the continent as europe
blinking in the bright light surveys the
damage
and challenges ahead first we track down
christian stanichich
director of the croatia national tourist
board in zagreb
and he told us just how much his
country's vital tourism sector
has been impacted globally the tourism
industry has been
impacted more than other industries
creation tourism has a huge impact on
croatian economy because it has
approximately 20 percent
of the gracious gdp during the
pandemic we stopped majority of
investment in tourism because of the
situation
and that has an impact on construction
industry on
of course transport equipment and so on
so what is croatia's tourism industry
worth
to the country what was the impact of
the pandemic and what's at stake
i will make a comparison with 2019
because it was
our best year ever in tourism we had in
2019
about 11 billion euros of income of
tourism
so it was really really successful
and we had also 1.5 billion euros
investment in croatia christian will be
talking to commissioner breton very
shortly
here's a chance for you however to put a
point to him directly to respond to
i would like to see that in the future
tourism in europe should have
a certain budget for which will be
available for
direct investment in tourism because not
every country is not at the same level
of tourism development
next we travel across the irish sea to
dublin and to colette bennett who works
for social justice
a civil society organization preoccupied
these days with chronic housing issues
what is your assessment colette of
what's been exposed about the state of
housing in ireland
that is swallowing up the government's
attention post covet
just how inadequate it is um so almost
since the beginning of the pandemic the
advice was to
stay at home to social distance to
flatten the curve and save lives
there were thousands of households who
couldn't do any of that
who were in the most vulnerable
situations where
social distancing wasn't an option let
alone you know self-isolation and so
many
urgently required things for you know a
building
of social housing um you know the
removal of families from
hotels and bed and breakfast into far
more suitable accommodation
the ramping up of domestic abuse
services
so you know there is huge investment
required
um across the board for very vulnerable
households
what do you expect the irish government
to do with its share of the 750 billion
euro fund rather than looking at these
very
large scale you know building a new
motorway
building a new commercial you know town
center on the outskirts of the town
we're looking at are you know proposing
that government actually take a much
more regional approach to it
to foster local economy to support
um local developers local builders
and to take a kind of a whole of life
cycle approach
our thanks there to christian stanichich
and collette bennett and now
back to continental europe and our key
guest eu commissioner
cherry brittle commissioner many thanks
again for joining us we'll turn to
questions in your portfolio as
commissioner for the internal market
as well as your other responsibilities
in defence and in vaccine delivery
shortly
but first your response to the
suggestion by christian stanichich in
croatia for a dedicated eu budget
to promote tourism we asked member
states to come back with a lot of ivs
to tackle the green transition and green
deal and of course the digital
transition and of course
the resilience part but just focusing on
the tourism industry that i think we
have a
very interesting opportunity now to
speed up let's say the transition
in this tourism ecosystem and also to
invest more
exactly like what has been asked
christian stanichich spoke
earlier of weaknesses exposed by covid
in his sector
what are the biggest points of
weaknesses do you think in europe's
economies following covert 19.
we can't speak of recovery now just
because of the success of the
vaccination strategy of the eu
at least the perception at the beginning
was shaky the reality is that
personally i believe that we will have
probably the best strategy from all
other continents
at the end of the day and when you see
that today we have been able to
so quickly first to develop new vaccines
and this is mainly
european research we'll be able to
deliver this is totally something
totally unprecedented
under those circumstances what did you
learn we learned many things and the
first thing is that
in the industrial strategy we have to
make sure that the supply chain for our
industry
especially for key industries will be
sustainable but also in semiconductors
and you know this is something i'm
pushing hard because i really think that
it will be a key a key part for our
industrial strategy
everywhere china has started to create a
lot of we started to create a lot of
stocks
stockpiling and then there's a big
description of the
semiconductor industry and the impact is
of course
that we are suffering in many areas
today in europe
especially in the automotive industry
but not only we learn
we need to increase our autonomy here in
specific
areas and and this is what
we are working on now next generation eu
it's an ambitious program for linking
immediate action to coherent
long-term plans tied to climate and
digital targets and preparedness for
future pandemics
what do you see as the immediate steps
overall
or straight away of course is definitely
to make sure that in every single
ecosystem
we know exactly how to support the risk
killing and preparedness of all the
workforce we need also to make sure that
the liquidity for some of
these companies and smes will be able to
sustain as a shock because we know that
that's an issue that we will have to cut
probably
within the second half of this year
let's turn to eu digital covert
certificates
the passport we've been told to holiday
travel and to reopening europe's tourism
industry
questions however have been raised along
the way that this is discriminatory
to citizens who haven't received full
numbers of doses
what's your take on this concern what is
extremely important is to remind to
everyone that this certificate is not
mandatory it is based on a voluntary
basis so i mean
you're not obliged to get a certificate
but by the way it could make your life
more easy
for example to cross border to maybe to
take a plan
or whatever and and in that regard we
thought it was extremely important
that we will have the same information
and same certificate in
the 27 countries of our continent
this information are very basic
information
at this point let's get some thoughts on
next steps in the covid recovery process
specifically relating to the 750 billion
euro recovery plan
here are four issues or direct questions
we'd like you to address commissioner
very kindly collected
by the enterprise europe network first
from ins
vixner director of the latvian
technological center
first of all we are thankful to
commissioner terry breton
for such possibility why the recovery
plan don't provide freedom to eu member
countries to identify problematic themes
by themselves
and adopt a recovery plan to local
business needs
commissioner the floor is yours it's the
first time in our history
that we are able to give so much money
for every single member states
but of course it is in addition to what
every single member states are doing
already for their own businesses
smes employees and country of course
next we go to roman arsenal who's with a
bulgarian cyber security company called
so cyber mr breton what is foreseen
in the plan for smes in the cyber
security sector
and in the i.t sector in general i know
it's a topic close to your heart
by the way everything is close to my
heart in my portfolio and i have a very
large spot for you i have a big heart if
i
say so so we have a lot of tools here
that's a very very important subject
uh 20 for the next generation eu just
for use
for i.t and finally dimitar stoyanov
also in bulgaria makes this observation
he describes himself as
an aspiring entrepreneur looking often
in vain
for capital investment the eu
significantly lags behind
other nations in the venture capital
sector and
many entrepreneurs from the eu are
forced to move to the us
or uk to develop their innovative
companies
this will likely have a very negative
impact on the competitiveness of the eu
in the long term how will the recovery
plan address this problem
well i know this uh let's say complain
and remark
last for many years in the case and i
think it changed a lot and of course i
don't want to criticize them because
i've been an entrepreneur myself i
started my own company myself when i was
20
25. i see the situation improving
drastically in europe of course we are
not yet
at the level of of the us let's say but
we have a lot of tools now
and also in the ecosystems you i mean of
course you need
you need the money and you need to have
the flexibility as you would describe
very well
but you need also to have the ecosystem
you need to have also the landscape you
need
also the skills you have learned and
this is why i strongly believe that
things are changing many thanks
commissioner for fielding these
questions from our listeners it's often
said
as i'm sure you've observed stephen as
well that today's workers have slid
unchecked and unprotected into a world
of decreasing wages
job precarity zero hours contracts and
fewer rights
now as europe's economies and industrial
sectors reboot
after kovid is this a chance to correct
that state of affairs
to live up to promises of a more robust
and socially just compact
between worker and employer luca
vicentini secretary general of the
european trade union confederation
definitely thinks so and the launch of
the cobit recovery plan
is just the moment to start so mr
vicentini what are your key demands to
the eu
for the distribution of this huge
package of funding well the key demand
is to spend the money well and to avoid
mistakes that have been done in the past
it's absolutely necessary to measure
exactly
how many quality jobs are going to be
created with this money
and also make sure that we can properly
manage the so-called transitions the
climate transition on the one side
and digital transition on the other side
in a way that is inclusive
nobody is left behind and we can really
create a good opportunity for all
do you believe workers rights are under
threat here in the mad rush back to
economic growth
and what i mean by that is is there
going to be a new gig economy
there is no new normal to recreate let's
say on the contrary we have to build
a more inclusive economy that can really
benefit people
in this respect having a strong social
dimension embedded in the recovery plans
is fundamental
social dimension means managing the
transition in adjusted way
but particularly creating jobs that are
quality jobs jobs that are protected and
it's also fundamental that
the social partners the trade unions in
particular from our point of view are
involved
in designing and implementing the
national recovery plans
is social solidarity needed here with
young people with women and with
marginalized
individuals i ask this because eurostat
surveys suggest
fewer people care about social issues
that the social agenda matters less
for ordinary people than wages and job
availability
we have really destroyed let's say this
privileged
situation in which europe was in the
past the fact that we have created
really
a socially inclusive economy that now
has been undermined
there is really an urgency to rebuild
all this this
must be absolutely uh the top priority
of the recovery strategy of the european
union and it's not by chance that
even president von der lyon underlines
all the time that we need
to rebuild our social market economy an
economy at the service of people
we'd like to put a question on your
behalf to commissioner bretol if you
were us
sitting right here in front of him what
point would you like to make
commissioner breton comes from the
private sector and
had very brilliant performances in the
private sector as a manager so i think
it is the best place person in the
commission to make sure that
together with vice president timmermans
he should design
concrete plans for just transition
commissioner that last point is for you
what's your response
that's a very good question and it's top
on our
list discussing with all the players the
company's
startups ngos unions
research centers universities discussing
of the midterm and long-term vision and
we have a vision we have a strategy
today
and then we are building this path
ecosystem per ecosystem in terms of
skills and then of course
in terms of quality jobs
let's turn now to europe's long-term
industrial strategy
a big priority for this commission the
strategy was revamped during the worst
of the pandemic
to take account of the new circumstances
and commissioner you head up this whole
process
so here's my question in the updated
industrial strategy
there's a big emphasis on building
single market resilience
post covid how exactly do you build up
sufficient resilience
to stand up to a pandemic of the
magnitude of covet
what did we learn we realized that in
with some of
our industry and supply chains we have
been put in a very difficult situation
and it was totally unexpected so we need
to be more resilient
this is why we decided to be more
resilient including pharmaceutical
industry just to make sure that
this will not happen again because it
was so painful
so then we decided to make a mapping of
what is
critical for us in our industry so we
identified five thousand
key product or source of supply which
were important
we identify 134 of them
which were extremely important and where
we we believed we were too dependent
of single source and on this 30-32
where we believe it's absolutely
critical to enforce ourselves
this is where as we draw to a close we
invite you monsieur bretton to reflect
rather fast
on issues outside of kobit 19 30 seconds
or under per each of the items we're
going to fire off
can you realize your dream of europe as
a center of microprocessor production
no i don't want to be there to be the
europe to be at the center of
microprocessor prediction i just
say that 30 years ago we were producing
40 percent of the capacity of the of
let's say the need of the world
in europe now it's a 9 and we believe
that
we should come back to 20 how realistic
is it as you would like
to create the googles and facebooks of
europe my goal is just to make sure that
we will have a clear rules for
informational space or digital space
which is now a new space in which we are
working hard in which we have a lot of
new activities so we just need to have
some rules
create more innovation and more
competitiveness
if there's one thing you want to do
before your sum holiday
what is it since you say that i have a
lot of let's say children in my
portfolio uh
i don't prefer one children i want all
of them succeed together at the same
time
many thanks commissioner thierry bruton
for these responses and for joining us
for our discussion on so many other
issues at the heart of europe's postcode
response
thank you very much and thank you for
your questions and the one from your
partners
thank you gentlemen now for millions of
europeans
and many more coming from outside music
festivals are an essential part of the
summer
at least they wear now they're bouncing
back
but how strongly are the conditions at a
festival
any festival big or small as ripe as you
could possibly find for transmission of
certain viruses
it's an issue serge plattel has grappled
with solidly for the past
18 months he's the director of the
federation of music festivals in
flanders the flemish region of belgium
does he foresee a recovery of the
festival scene in time for the summer
season
we need to have full capacity no social
distancing and that's
the main festivals that they need that
to be able to organize
on a level that they can they don't lose
money
we need the vaccination that everybody
has to have
one vaccine at least one vaccine or have
the possibility to have one vaccine
and if that's delayed because of the
vaccines are not coming then
we won't be able to start up big
festivals like
tomorrowland can future proof themselves
how about the many
smaller ones if we are able to have a
digital green pass fully working
on the month of july and people can use
it people can work with it i think the
cost will be limited or hopefully will
be less
for the organization what would you
demand of the eu
in terms of the support it gives to
national governments in the field of
culture
we are in unusual times so unusual
measures should be able
and and if the local governments uh
think that it's necessary and it's it's
important enough to support
then i hope the european government will
not restrain them
thanks there to serge platel from the
federation of music festivals
in flanders in belgium bye-bye
this has been europe calling our thanks
also to commissioner breton and to all
our other guests who've joined us
that just about wraps it up our next
podcast due out in july before the
summer break
will focus on climate change and the
green deal as well as on digital
transformation
the eu's other big projects until then
take care and goodbye goodbye
[Music]
what started with a virus so small your
eyes couldn't see it this is about
providing a future for humanity the
commission has decided to find google
4.34 billion euros
[Music]
this is europe's man on the moon moment
we are innovating here and we hope that
you like it
[Music]
you